we've got some breaking news just coming
into US actor Alec Baldwin is expected
to face involuntary manslaughter charges
over the film set shooting in 2021.
Baldwin was pointing a gun on the set of
the film rust when it went off wounding
and killing cinematographer haliana
Hutchins I'll correspondent Rob Reynolds
is in Los Angeles Forest so Rob Baldwin
now facing charges is that coming as a
surprise
well this is the result of a 15-month
long investigation since the fatal
shooting on the set of the western uh
film rust and uh in addition to Alec
Baldwin the armorer of the Set uh who
was on the set 24 year old Hannah
Gutierrez
apologies for that we seem to have lost
audio with Rob Reynolds we will try to
reconnect in just a moment Rob can you
hear us
arms and weapons on the set are the
assistant director of the film also
pleaded guilty uh in a plea deal to a
charge of negligent use of a deadly
weapon now
um what happened was that re uh a gun
which was supposed to be a cold gun in
other words without any weap any bullets
in it was handed to Alec Baldwin he
discharged it it hit Helena Hutchins the
cinematographer also uh Joel Souza the
director was wounded uh Hutchins died
shortly thereafter from a chest wound uh
Baldwin has claimed repeatedly that he
would never have fired the gun he said
it misfired somehow when he cocked the
hammer of this uh sort of antique Colt
45 revolver but he settled with the
family of Helena Hutchins last year for
an undisclosed sum of money what happens
next uh it will be that there will be
clearly legal proceedings underway uh
taking place in Santa Fe New Mexico and
these charges of negligent homicide will
be will be brought before a jury uh and
uh more on this uh tragic incident uh
sort of really unprecedented in modern
Hollywood will will unfold at that time
we have a big day of developments in
what was a very big story thank you very
much Rob Reynolds for joining us there
from Los Angeles